hi this is Dr Gregory Sadler I'm a
professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason I O
where we put philosophy into practice
I've studied and taught Philosophy for
over 20 years and I find that many
people run into difficulties reading
classic philosophical texts
sometimes it's the way things are said
or how the text is structured
but the concepts themselves are not
always that complicated and that's where
I come in
to help students and lifelong Learners
I've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to YouTube many
viewers say they find them useful
what you're currently watching is part
of a new series of shorter videos each
of them focused on One Core concept from
an important philosophical text I hope
you find it useful as well
as you can well expect Joseph Butler's
sermon number nine which is titled upon
forgiveness of injuries is going to talk
about some of those biblical precepts
that have to do with forgiving those who
wrong us and loving enemies and he
touches on this at several points and
he's got some important things to tell
us I think a good place to start is with
a sort of equation that he is making and
this is a deep in the sermon he says as
to that love of our enemies which is
commanded commanded by who by by God
this precept is no more than to forgive
injuries right so the two of them for
him are basically the same thing he says
what does this mean well there's a
general obligation to to benevolence or
Good Will to human beings that extends
to sort of a general obligation to
people you know Humanity at large and
then also to a lot of specific people in
our lives so if we suppose that then we
can equate these two because they're
basically going to come down to that
obligation and one other one which is
connected to it which is as he says to
keep clear of those abuses
before mentioned what are those abuses
the ones that are being discussed in
sermon eight and here in sermon nine
abuses of anger anger has legitimate
purposes for Butler God gave it to us uh
not just as a defect but for doing
certain things but it's pretty easy for
us human beings to go astray with anger
so we have to be careful and forgiving
our enemies or
loving our enemies is going to be part
of that and it doesn't just mean loving
enemies loving human beings in general
so backtracking a little bit to the
beginning of the sermon he says that
um
what are these precepts to forgive and
love enemies actually require of us so
first he tells us that the precepts to
forgive and to love our enemies do not
relate to that General indignation
against injury and the authors of it so
General indignation meaning like
indignation that has to do with
situations that don't directly concern
us but where we're like yeah that's
screwed up people shouldn't be doing
that they shouldn't be behaving that way
in relation to others and then he says
it does pertain to this feeling or
resentment when raised by private or
personal injury so people do things to
us to those that we care about the
people within our Circles of concern you
could say those who we identify with or
have some sort of obligation to and then
we we get angry and the question is well
what do we actually do with the anger
does forgiving our enemies require us
not to be angry and you know Butler is
going to say it doesn't actually forbid
the feeling
we can be angry at people and provided
we're not allowing that anger to you
know grow to greatly or distort our
views on things we're actually not doing
the wrong thing what it does he says is
forbid excess and abuse of that personal
feeling right
he says in cases of of personal and
private injury
and this is something that we actually
do have to be quite careful about now a
little bit later on he is going to talk
about something that is
often overlooked we typically behave or
assume uh you know we we treat these
things in this way as if one feeling
rules out another feeling so if I'm
angry at you then I don't love you
anymore and Butler says no that's that's
not the case at all resentment or anger
is compatible with what he calls good
will or benevolence he says we often see
both together in very high degrees
meaning developed to a considerable
extent what are the examples that he
gives I think this is very relatable for
all of us parents and children you can
love your kids you can do right by them
you can exercise benevolence or Goodwill
towards them and be like you are in
a-hole you're really getting on my last
freaking nerve can't you just stop your
stupid Behavior this could go both ways
right this could be the children
misbehaving and the parents love them
but they're also angry with them it
could also be screw-up parents who are
doing the wrong thing as well and it's
not just parents and children as he's
going to tell us
it extends to all sorts of other
relationships as well he talks about
friendship and relationships of
dependence so you know perhaps something
like uh employee to employer right they
can get angry with each other or a
teacher to student there's a kind of
dependency relationship there
client to Patron we could come up with
all sorts of examples and he says that
it's actually very common where we both
feel angry resentful and we also you
know love the other person in the sense
at least of displaying Goodwill and
benevolence and he says we may therefore
love our enemy and yet have resentment
against him for his injurious behavior
towards us the problem that arises as he
says when this resentment entirely
destroys our natural benevolence towards
him
it is excessive and becomes malice or
Revenge so the command to prevent its
having this effect to forgive enemies is
the same injuries is the same as to love
our enemies because that love is always
supposed unless destroyed by a
resentment so we can feel resentful
that's okay so long as we don't allow it
not just to lead to abuses but to root
out or we could even say just neutralize
the natural benevolence the natural
willing good to the other person as a
human being that we should feel
he's also got a very interesting example
here about
cases where we might actually have to do
something to another person he says
if lower in instances of injury May
lessen our benevolence so you know when
people do things that are kind of minor
to us it makes us less benevolent
towards them why may not hire the
highest destroy it and he says the
answer is obvious now the answer isn't
quite so obvious and he actually has to
spell it out and he makes three very
interesting
uh distinctions here or we could say a
tripartite distinction he says it is not
man's being a social creature much less
his being a moral agent from Wenzel
owner obligations to Goodwill towards
him arise
there is an obligation to it prior to
either of these arising from him being a
sensible creature so these are three
different ways in which we can look at
other human beings and ourselves
we can understand ourselves as a
social creature that is or sometimes
it's translated as political we are the
kind of animal that exists in
relationships and in society we can also
understand ourselves as moral beings as
capable of responsibility free choice
weighing different options prioritizing
screwing things up getting things right
all of that that's quite important but
we can also look at human beings as what
he's calling here sensible and what does
that mean
to be sensible is to be capable of
happiness or misery or we could think of
this as creatures that can be gratified
or pleased and creatures that can be
disappointed or suffer that can be made
miserable so given that other human
beings can be made miserable by us we
should refrain from doing that that's
part of what benevolence involves and we
should actually try to improve their
conditions now that's not to say that
sociality or morality don't matter but
there's something yet more basic for
Butler
so he goes on and he says this
obligation cannot be superseded by his
moral character right what's what does
he mean there well if they're a bad
person the kind of person that we get
angry at because they do bad things
we still have a duty of benevolence to
them and then he says okay well what
about when we kill criminals what about
when we do public executions
and here you know like some people might
say well you gotta they did something
wrong therefore you know since they
offended we have to do something bad to
them and write the scales and that is
not how Butler looks at it at all he
says instead that
um the the guilt or the demerit of the
criminal does not dispense with the
obligation of good The Good Will neither
would this justify any severity What
does justify executing them their life
is inconsistent with the quiet and
happiness of the world and so another
way of looking at this he says a general
and more enlarged obligation necessarily
destroys a particular and more confined
one of the same kind inconsistent with
it we normally would be benevolent good
willing towards the criminal but because
of the way in which they behave we also
have to think about everybody else who
is affected in Society by the bad
actions of the criminal and therefore we
execute them we incapacitate them we put
them in prison whatever it's going to be
right
so we don't do this
lacking Goodwill but we have to suspend
our Goodwill towards that person so that
we can exercise
Goodwill towards everybody else
um he goes on and he talks about
um
this Divine precept he says if all of
this is true what can a person say who
will dispute the reasonableness or the
possibility of obeying the Divine
precept we're now considering let him
speak out and it must be like this that
he will speak a human being as defective
and faulty the proper object of my good
will whatever his faults are when they
respect others but not when they respect
me myself and he says no you also need
to think about yourself as as being like
other people in this respect and so he
says thus love to our enemies and those
who have been injurious to us is so far
from being a rant what does he mean by a
rant well this is a term that we use
today but back then they used it to mean
like crazy talk right the things that
people would argue that are completely
off-based
so he says that it's actually a
law of our nature to love enemies
and what everyone must see and own who
is not blinded by self-love our own
self-love tends to make us more focused
on thinking in terms of how we are
affected right so somebody does
something wrong to us we see it as a
bigger deal than it is we we get angry
we we feel resentful we we don't want to
be good willing towards them and
um what what do we have to do so here's
what what um
what Butler is going to say
and what is the degree in which we're
commanded to love our enemies or those
who have been injurious to us it would
be well if it could be as easily reduced
to practiced it cannot be imagined that
we are required to love them with any
sort of affection so you know think
about friends and family we love them in
a sense that goes beyond just being
benevolent to them being good to them
wishing good to them we actually care
about them we actually feel affection
towards them we don't have to love
enemies in that way that's asking too
much
he says
suppose the person injured to have a do
natural sense of the injury and no more
he ought to be affected towards the
injurious person in the same way any
good men uninterested in the case would
be if they had the same just sense which
we suppose the injured person have of
the fault after which there will yet
remain real good will
towards the offender so what are we
being commanded to do we're not we don't
have to love in the sense of the
affection of love but we should have
good will towards the person who is
offending against us and the way that we
can do that is by getting away from our
own
particularity our own focus on ourself
and thinking about how other people
would make sense of it he says now what
is there in all this which should be
thought impracticable I'm sure there's
nothing in it unreasonable it's indeed
no more that we should not indulge a
passion the what passion The Passion of
anger so it's okay for us to actually
feel anger to a certain extent not to
the extent that it drives us into doing
the wrong things we can be angry with
offenders and yet Feel Good Will
benevolence towards them and you know
presumably if we catch ourselves losing
that we could say well how would other
people see this if they were if it
wasn't me and it was somebody else how
would I be looking at this situation
could I still have benevolence towards
that person this is a cognitive remedy
you could say and that would allow us to
exhibit at least in this understanding
love of enemies and forgiveness of
injuries